[Musique]
17 heures passées à Chartres Lucile
Julot 34 ans arrive sur son lieu
d'entraînement un petit bar de quartier
situé en basse ville trois soirs par
semaine seul ou contre un adversaire
Lucy l'enchaîne les cibles un passibles
et toujours avec la même précision
c'est surtout de la concentration
la gestion du stress parce qu'en
compétition ça qui va faire la
différence parce qu'il y en a à
l'entraînement ou facile d'être le
champion de l'entraînement mais une fois
que tu arrives en complète il y a la
pression des enjeux c'est vraiment pas
la même donc c'est vraiment beaucoup de
la gestion du stress c'est ce moment où
la pression monte j'arrive à la faire
redescendre à rester dans mon match à
vraiment rester focus sur mon objectif
et
cette capacité à gérer ses émotions a
fait de Lucile une machine à gagner
entre 2017 et 2022 elle est sacrée trois
fois championne de France de fléchettes
électroniques autre prouesse en octobre
dernier pour la deuxième fois
consécutive elle remporte le championnat
européen organisé au Portugal un
palmarès aujourd'hui affiché fièrement
donc ça c'est ce titané donc ça c'est
celle en individuel championnat de
France et celle qu'on a eu en doublette
et après ça c'est les deux du Portugal
en individuel et en équipe où on a fait
la finale aussi on l'a pas gagné mais on
a fait la finale
elle n'était pourtant pas destinée à un
tel niveau car c'est par hasard dans ce
même bar que Lucile découvre les
fléchettes en 2014 avec sa grande sœur
Audrey je jouais de temps en temps ici
et j'ai entendu parler d'un tournoi du 9
Marco 20 donc j'ai proposé à ma petite
sœur de le faire avec moi parce que je
pensais qu'on allait passer un bon
moment vu
et effectivement on a passé un très bon
moment
depuis je continue à jouer pas aussi
bien qu'elle mais j'apprécie toujours
autant surtout la convivialité cette
passion Lucile la partage également avec
son compagnon Arnaud qui n'est autre que
le maître des lieux ensemble ils ont
d'ailleurs gagné un championnat de
France en doublette c'est lui qui a
organisé les tous premiers tournois
auxquels Lucie la participé en
Eure-et-Loir son établissement est un
incontournable pour les mordus de
fléchettes on a commencé ici au début il
y avait
ont été six à jouer et aujourd'hui on
est 43 donc en effet il y a beaucoup de
beaucoup de passionnés et plus ça va en
plus plus on a donc ça c'est ça c'est
super pour les pour le développement des
fléchettes sur la région en pierre
représentante de sa région et de la
France Lucie la décroché un billet pour
affronter les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
en octobre prochain à Las Vegas avec
pourquoi pas un titre mondial en ligne
de mire